aujourd'hui fat and entrevue franck 15
et motivés à chercher du boulot il n'a
pas le choix c'est une
les conditions de la maison passion il a
été condamné il ya trois mois pour un
vol par effraction une quatrième fois en
quinze ans il a eu la chance il a pu
être libéré au sixième de sa peine de
neuf mois de prison si j'allais rester
six mois en prison sur neuf jarre est
sorti je ne devrais plus rien puis
serait comme quoi l'amour dit société on
s'en fout de toute façon une bonne pâte
chan
ouais même s'il partage un appartement
avec sa conjointe il doit passer ses
nuits ici à la maison saint laurent dans
le nord de montréal
gourgeon oui il doit aussi se rapporter
régulièrement directeur de la maison de
transition et se soumettre à un
encadrement sévère on est la porte des
grès socialement et ancien ronde
s'assurer que ce que tu as faim parce
que tu as des fonctions de migration
concernant les respectacles abstinence
de drogue et d'alcool
présence obligatoire les activités avec
ses colocataires suivi de thérapie il
avait un sérieux problème de drogue ont
choisi de suspendre capelle j'avais pas
de problème avec les autres dragster
mais deux matches en hausse de presque 3
franck est un habitué des centres de
détention au fil des années il y a vu
les conditions se détériorer nous notre
montée déchiré chez directement après le
plancher de gémenos
on sait jamais c'est la personne qui
appelle mac là avant nous ce cas le
virus dont elle avait dessus des
maladies
selon wayne john howard society 55 % des
détenus sont en fait des prévenus c'est
à dire qu'ils n'ont pas encore été jugés
donc présumé innocent c'est une tendance
depuis 20 ans sous la gouverne du parti
libéral déjà la mise en liberté sous
caution avant procès est de plus en plus
difficiles à obtenir
la plupart des prisons sont surpeuplées
financièrement la surpopulation que cher
et il ya quand même un budget limité
donc ce que ça pourrait faire des fois
de supprimer un certain nombre de cette
surpopulation est aggravée par les
effets des nombreuses lois et mesures
promulgué au cours des dix dernières
années dans le but 10 des conservateurs
de rendre justice aux victimes et de
lutter plus fermement contre la
criminalité et si je fais le métier de
sellier de compenser la main
daniel benson condamné à la prison à vie
à l'âge de 19 ans pour le meurtre
prémédité de son beau-père qui brutalise
est sa mère après 17 ans de prison où il
a obtenu un bac en théologie il est et
sera jusqu'à sa mort en libération
conditionnelle
en vertu de la loi s6 adopter en 2011
qui a aboli ce qu'on appelait la clause
de la dernière chance
il n'aurait jamais pu être libéré sous
conditions sitôt réfère 25 ans de prison
minimalement serait sorti de prison dix
ans peut-être
de plus j'aurais eu beaucoup plus de
difficultés en série
daniel benson regrette son geste il
consacre maintenant sa vie à la
réinsertion sociale des ex détenus
fédéraux les cas les plus lourds
il supervise trois résidences comme
celle ci donne des conférences et siège
au conseil d'administration d'un
organisme aide aux familles touchées par
le crime
9 un détenu coûte 120 mille dollars par
année à la société en communauté un
ex-détenu coûterait environ 35000
dollars
daniel benson travaillait avec d'autres
ex détenu à option vie un programme d'
aide à la réintégration sociale
d'anciens criminels violents
le gouvernement fédéral l'a aboli qu'en
je pense que c'est une question
idéologique de vengeance simplement
dérangeant ce pur et dur
deux émissions méchant on va les garder
en prison pour boni punir davantage
stephen harper et les conservateurs ne
se sont jamais caché de vouloir serrer
la vis aux criminels et ils promettent
de le faire plus encore lors d'un
prochain mandat éliminant la libération
conditionnelle automatique pour les
délinquants récidivistes et violent
en 2012 ils ont adopté ces dix une loi
omnibus sur la sécurité des rues et des
communautés elles resserrent les
conditions de sursis de libération
conditionnelle et de pardon le résultat
est paradoxale sous prétexte de
combattre la criminalité alors qu'elle
ne cesse de diminuer
on augmente les facteurs qui risquent de
la faire croître
plusieurs provinces et le barreau du
québec conteste ces 10 devant les
tribunaux
dans les années 70 on avait des dizaines
parce que entre au cabinet gens qui
n'avaient plus rien à perdre
en faisant autant qu'à rester ici et
je vais essayer de faire une prise
d'otages fermez menthe m'évader et ces
genres de situations auxquelles on
risque d'être confronté dans les
prochaines années
les gardiens de prisons n'attendront pas
dix ans pour faire connaître leur
mécontentement
gardiens et détenus même combat ils sont
ouvertement en campagne contre stephen
europe
j'ai l'impression que c'est une façon
d'aller chercher encore plus de votes et
c'est de la poudre aux yeux
parce que nous autres au niveau du
système correctionnel les membres du
syndicat des employés de ces salles on
croit en la récession et on croit la
réhabilitation je suis depuis cette
entrevue franck à trouver du travail
cette fois il compte bien réussir et
abandonner ses mauvaises habitudes
le jeune et la chance c'est ce qu'a
mentionné mots c'est fini pour moi ça
paraît qu'il faut ça s'arrête
aujourd'hui sa conjointe depuis onze ans
valérie a l'intention d'être très
vigilante un an atteint un débit dans
quel
tout ce que le l'avenir et va de l'avant
donc sauf que pour qui il va vouloir
changer beaucoup de choses comme ça a
déjà commencé
moi je suis là pour le soutenir